It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 137th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you, Mococo!
No!
Moco-chan's always like this.
This is how I always am!
BAU BAU!
137!
Keep on climbing up!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday aka FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us,
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag!
It's not Hashtag!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's the hashtag!
You know that, right?
BAU BAU!
It's Friday, Mofus!
It's Friday!
We've done it!
We're here!
A fun weekend coming up!
Right!
And there's been so many exciting things going on!
Let's get right to it, Moco-chan!
Well... First... Disappointment.
Cause you know...
It's been another Pero Sighting.
I'm thankful but disappointed.
BAU BAU!
Where did you see Pero this time, Ruffians?
Let's take a look.
De-den.
Ah, ah, wait.
Huh?
BAUMARKET.
Perroccino.
BAUMARKET!
I don't know.
I guess you know sometimes you run into nasty customers.
You know there's lots of different types of customers out there, right?
But I think you run into Pero at the store.
I don't know.
You think he's there for demon dog treats?
Really?
I don't know about that, you know.
It seems more like maybe pudding, but I don't know if they sell pudding there.
Yeah, I think they have plants, not pudding plants.
Yeah!
I haven't seen Pero eating plants before.
Moco-chan, you could've wanted to try taking a bite out of a succulent here, right?
They look delicious.
I'm not going to, but they look delicious!
You never know, right?
Pero hasn't eaten many plants, but... He could eat dirt for all I care.
He doesn't need pudding.
Dirt is good enough.
They do have lots of different types of soil in these kind of places, right?
Yeah, and it's good to try new things!
Right!
Pero can try that, try some dirt!
Ruffians!
You know, you can try something new.
That's not eating dirt.
Please.
What?
No, no dirt tasting.
Just more pedo-lucky.
You bought him from the store.
That's probably a good idea.
Dicking.
Or you can give him some free dirt.
Let's find some samples.
BAU BAU!
Pero deserves all the pudding!
All the dirt.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Another one of our big big dreams came true!
Something that means so much to us.
It happened!
Our first original song, Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★, has reached over 1 million views on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's time!
Thank you, Ruffians!
The point of this battle is super duper special to us.
We shared it with you during our first anniversary.
We were able to perform it for the very first time during our 3D debut.
And then, you know the very first song that we performed on stage?
Just the two of us!
Breaking the mentions of battle.
You know, when we hit 1 million 1 million Ruffians here on YouTube, it was exactly what we were singing.
So many numbers.
Right!
Thank you Ruffians for listening to it.
Lots and lots and lots!
I get GTA 2 high.
Yeah!
Lots of special moments.
And you know,
FUWAMOCO, we know you know that music is really important to us.
So to know that, Ruffians, that you enjoy our music and you want to hear more of it from us, it really means so much to us.
You know, FUWAMOCO, we're gonna continue to do our best, bring even more music to you!
I would hope so.
Yeah, I think so, Moco-chan.
You know BAU will just hit 1 million.
Gonna work hard and strive to reach our goal!
The goal of having our own solo live one day!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for 1 million views!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
It's a very special day, cute Ruffians!
Wow!
Not just "BAU"DOL hitting 1 million, but there's been a lot of excitement and buzz going on amongst the Ruffians!
Yeah, and that's because Round1!
Round1 is a chain of arcades, karaoke, entertainment centers!
Right now they have a very special hololive collab going on!
And starting today... Wow!
Dictate with some plushies!
You know FUWAMOCO plushies!
Not just you know the Tire Force and some other merch, but yes, around in America you can get hololive plushies!
Plushies!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO plushies, yes!
You can bring home your own FUWAMOCO plushies!
Are you going tomorrow to try your luck?
Good luck!
FUWAMOCO!
What's been announced so far is the locations that have pushes started today are Marina Valley Mall, Arlington Park, South Center Mall, East Ridge Shopping Center, Grapevine Mills, Sun Valley Mall, X-10 Square Mall, Southwest Plaza, Broadway Mall, Galleria and Crystal Run, Fully Seasons Town Center, Northridge Mall, Southland Mall, Park Place Mall,
Fall!
Meadows Mall.
Westfield Gallery at Roseville.
Arrowhead Town Center.
And Westfield Plaza Bonitas.
BAU BAU!
Hopefully your mall will include the two Ruffians.
Japan doko?
Japan doko ni mo nai yo!
Gomen!
So amigurumi wa Amerika genten deshiyo!
The flushies at Round1, they're limited to America.
So we hope you can get your paws on more feelings.
And you know, especially if you're a little bit worried you're traveling a long distance, we think it wouldn't hurt to go ahead and just see, you know?
It never hurts to ask.
Yeah, but we really hope that you have a ton of fun in Round1!
That you do your best at the creating machines!
Yeah, good luck!
And maybe explore the arcade games too!
Have some of the yummy FUWAMOCO foods!
Yeah, and try to get the coasters too!
Yeah, the random coasters!
And maybe you can do some power-ups!
Yeah!
Maybe they have bottom, maybe they don't.
We'll see!
You'll have to see!
But...
You know, you can't afford a ticket out of your hotel room.
I was gonna say, Ruffians, you know, if you're not in the US and you're feeling a little sad that you can't get your paws on FUWAMOCO plushies.
FUWAMOCO, our hololive friends with you has just been announced!
So now you can go to the
Official hololive shop!
It's not that far away, huh?
No, it's online!
Just a click!
A click of the mouse!
And you can get them there and they'll be coming to your doorstep very soon too!
Yeah!
You're all together with Alphys!
BAU BAU!
But we don't have toys.
Right!
So, right arriving in November maybe?
I'm gonna have to look forward to it.
We sure are!
FUWAMOCO fans have a lot of fun!
And soon, FUWAMOCO plushies will be in your paws too.
Soon enough.
Bye bye!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah, there were some problems out of all our control.
But we think there was still a lot of fun to be had.
And you know, especially because a special hololive English ULB album was released!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO.
Did you listen, Ruffians?
Well, you know, not just my senpai songs, but even FUWAMOCO.
Born to be BAU-do and rebellion too.
We now have super cool URLV versions out there.
Amazing, right?
It sounds so good, right?
Yeah!
Right?
Terrific!
Yeah, it will be!
Where?
You can listen on the official hololive English channel.
Yeah, there's a video.
Yeah, I think it'll be on streaming service soon.
Maybe?
I don't know.
But a big big thank you to the crazy talented chihuahua who created these remixes!
Thank you!
This means Ruffians, now you can listen and BAU BAU at the speed of light!
Don't go too fast.
Don't go too fast, but you know maybe you can play your own racing games at home!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
But we really love the remixes so much!
We hope you listen to them lots and lots, okay?
A little bit of a different ballroom vibe.
And you know, in celebration of this FUWAMOCO English you'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll be- You'll
There's some stickers!
Yeah!
Of everybody super duper cute!
The stickers you can see down here, and there's FUWAMOCO stickers too!
FUWAMOCO together!
Yeah, you know!
And a super cute illustration from Lian!
Thank you!
But not just a sticker!
There's also an extra special really cute thing!
This time it's kind of in the style of a CD!
Right!
It's very cute!
It's a CD, right?
What do you think it's a record, Moco-chan?
Maybe it's a record.
A record, a CD, the round shaped thing that plays music.
Yes!
The round thing that plays music, yes!
You thought it was a tire?
It could be a tire.
Maybe you'll have to get your paws on it and check it out.
Is it a CD?
Is it a record?
Is it just a flattened tire?
A vinyl.
Oh.
Isn't a record and vinyl the same thing?
FUWAMOCO Final is a mystery!
Please check it out!
BAU BAU!
If you put it on your record player will you hit bottom?
I don't think so.
I don't know if your record player is small enough.
If you have a tiny one then maybe.
Only insects can hear it.
BAU BAU!
Wow, there's been so many things going on, you might have missed it.
But!
Wow.
The ultimate hololive experience is back!
It was just announced that Super Expo 2025 and 6 events will be happening at Mocuhari-Vision next year!
2025, March 8th and March 9th in FUWAMOCO!
Six great events!
BAU BAU!
Here we go, Ruffians!
We're so so excited!
We know FUWAMOCO will be a part of Super Expo this year!
That was this year.
Right?
That was this year!
That feels like forever ago.
But ya'll whole life continues!
We're gonna be having Super Expo and Six Fest at Makuhari Mansion!
I wonder who could be there.
Ruffians, there's still a bunch of new FUWAMO coming soon, so please look forward to that!
But!
While this year's theme has been announced, the theme is hololive Arcade!
And what it seems like right now, they want to make the ultimate hololive drink created by you, Ruffians!
I know, it's very interesting, very exciting.
Maybe you know something very colorful?
Gaming colors!
Lots of arcade excitement in it!
Do you have drink ideas, Ruffians?
RGB!
You're weird!
Soggy jewel drink!
Okay, I'm worried too.
Nerissa's white?
Wow, Abyss!
Hi!
Like, I was thinking, you know, I don't know about the drink, but there'll be something probably really delicious, like, ramune or something!
Yeah!
But I was thinking, you know, like, a sugar icing triangle, like the whole, like, triangle!
Have fun!
Oh, like, sprinkles inside the drink, falling down, cute!
Yeah!
Maybe bubbles, like, popping bubbles or something!
Like, like, like, pachi pachi!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
If you have any ideas, Ruffians are looking for all kinds of ideas in a google form.
You can submit your ideas.
So please go check it out.
This is my moment!
I have the ultimate hololive drink here in my brain.
You do not have much time.
You have to have your ideas by Halloween, okay?
A little bit earlier than Halloween, because... Ah, true, it's JST.
Before Halloween, okay?
Yeah, get to work on it, huh?
Please look forward to it.
Nattou juice?
I don't know.
Nattou and arcade really go that well together.
Not really on theme, huh?
But it was a good idea.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Please look forward to Super Expo 2025 at 6pm!
BAU BAU!
There's been some more announcements!
Can you believe it?
The other day...
Dear Calli-senpai, she had her 3.0 reveal, you know.
I feel like 2.0 is just a few months ago.
Right, it was just a little while ago.
Calli-senpai's looking even more cute!
Yeah!
But she also had some really big announcements!
Yeah, not only just the cute 3.0 body, she announced that she's gonna be having a J-Rap 3D launch!
Yeah!
J-Rap in jigoku!
FUWAMOCO!
It's so cool!
Right!
And this live will be on October 31st at 6am P.T.
Sorry, 5am.
5am P.T.
or 9pm JST.
So it's Halloween.
Before Halloween.
But it's not a Halloween theme.
It's not a Halloween theme, but you know, Kyary-chan's already pretty Halloween, right?
Yeah, it's J-Rap.
J-Rap is so good.
Ruffians, you definitely won't want to miss this one!
I think this is gonna be very very cool, Ruffians!
I think you know that you'll definitely not want to miss your halloween!
Even though you might be up late on halloween.
It's also a good idea to maybe be awake.
Halloween too!
Yeah!
You know you're gonna eat a lot of candy anyways, so you'll be able to stay up, right?
All that sugar!
How does that work?
You... It's in the morning of Halloween.
You eat... You eat candy!
You eat candy at 5am, and then you eat candy at 8am, and then you eat more candy all throughout the day, and then before you know it, it's midnight!
Halloween!
Not candy
Candy-o-pe!
Candy-o-pe?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
The Calli Senpai also revealed an MV for her song Lose, Lose, Dance!
Did you see it, Abyss?
That was super special, very emotional, you know?
It includes all of Myth and, you know, really talks about the journey that they've been on all together over the years.
It was really, really sweet.
But if you want to be a bit emotional, we recommend it!
I was getting teary.
Right!
Please check it out, Ruffians!
We really liked it!
It's such a good MV, right?
Yeah, it really brought to me.
Please check it out!
Wow, Ruffians!
We also have an important announcement to share with you today, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning will be going into a hibernation period starting next Friday.
But Ruffians, don't be late!
Don't be late, okay?
It will be back on Monday, March 10th at 8AM PT.
This is also together, you know, with the daylight, ceilings, time changes, everything.
FUWAMOCO Morning is something that's really special to both you and us.
It's hard for us to see go into a little bit of a hibernation time.
You know us Ruffians, we've been running at top speed since the moment we debuted!
And you know, we both feel like we need to prioritize our health now!
So that's what we're going to do as well, is focus on all the things we want to explore that we haven't been able to yet!
You know, there's a lot of things we really want to do!
A lot of things upcoming!
So we're going to aim to do those things as well as put our health on priority!
I know, but we'll really miss spending mornings together with you.
Especially, you know, in those colder months when it's hard to get out of bed.
It's a bittersweet decision, but we're still here!
Yes!
And we'll be doing even more cool things!
Yeah, okay!
And of course, we'll be streaming too, okay?
And like we said, FUWAMOCO Morning will be back when the clocks change again, March 10th at 8AM PT!
Got it!
Okay, Ruffians!
Yeah, so you better make up for it, okay?
Until then, let's enjoy the next FUWAMOCO Mornings we have together, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
It starts next Friday, okay?
Next Friday will be the last FUWAMOCO Morning before High Foundation, okay?
So let's enjoy it together!
Thank you so much, Mocos, for always being here with us in FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Let's check out today's Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Totoro!
Dominic Totoro!
Where ears?
Triangle ears.
What world is this?
I can see a square there too, but I guess it's most commonly referred to as Perfectly Triangle.
Yes.
But!
Well Totoro!
Totoro has a very important job.
Not only is he the guard dog of his Ruffians, their family, but also a secret agent.
Secret agent?
Yeah.
No one knows what his job exactly entails.
But it's probably best this way, you know.
I hear it looks so cheetah, but apparently it's a little bit vicious.
He also loves to bite sandals.
As long as it's just sandals.
I think it's just sandals.
Yes!
Moco-chan had his Totoro BAU BAU.
BAU!
Wow, I wouldn't expect that, but you know I guess it is Totoro!
We have a very fluffy and mini secret agent here!
Totoro!
I feel like right now, I'm very glad that I'm not a sandal.
I'm not a sandal!
I'm Mococo!
I'm Fuwawa!
I don't think we can take him down, right?
I think these Ruffians, you know, they have a very special doggy protecting their smiles.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You've been out taking some walks.
Let's see where you've been!
Today, I went on a walk!
Wee-haw!
De-den!
You went to the Chill Travel event in Taichung!
Chill Travel!
We're so happy!
It looks like you had tons of fun, and together with your friend Kevin, too!
And pon-de-rings!
Oh my gosh, so many!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Kevin!
Thank you for coming!
We're so happy!
BAU BAU!
Those are for us, right?
Right.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Question of the Day!
The Question of the Day is... De-den!
What kind of outfits do you like to see fans make for you the most?
Should they be reposted if you take a long time returning to the game?
Good question!
FUWAMOCO we're always so so happy with our fans' outfits!
They're really anything you'd like to see!
We're so happy and love seeing what you're up to!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Not always, but just sometimes.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you again for all your submissions for FUWAMOCO Morning!
There's only a week of FUWAMOCO Morning before hibernation.
So we'd really love to be able to see your Doggie of the Day!
And all the sightings you may have had happen.
Questions!
Or you know, the walks that you've been going on.
Please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you always so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Well, let's take a look at our next stream coming up here!
Our next stream is De-den!
Five Nights at Freddy's!
It's Friday!
Which means Friday night at Freddy's!
But five nights.
Last time we know, we were so close to beating one.
Apparently we did very well, but I think that's because of the Ruffians helping us.
So we're gonna need your help again so we can get through all five night at Freddy's, okay Ruffians?
We hope that you'll join us and kinda get a little bit of a head start into the Halloween spookiness.
It's not harder.
Sometimes, you know, when I make a sequel, it's like, huh?
I think it's pretty easy, you know?
Please help us!
We'll also be doing a watchalog of Mikochi-senpai's Solo Live!
That starts at 1.45am!
It's a little bit early, but it's Mikochi-senpai's first Solo Live!
We're so live and we're so excited to be able to see it!
So you know if you can't sleep, yeah I can't sleep.
Right.
Maybe you can sort of check it out a bit.
Yeah, please join us!
We are really happy because we got Mikochi-senpai phone last time.
We got to wish her best of luck beforehand.
Will she cry?
Will we cry?
That's the question.
We'll have to see!
BAU BAU!
And then on Saturday evening, we're playing Vsauce.
I think this is maybe the scariest horror game.
As you know, most horror games are very scary to us.
So why is FUWAMOCO playing the scariest one?
We told Kelly-senpai that we're playing this one and she chuckled.
We're playing it because Fubuki-senpai recommended we do it.
And then on Sunday we're gonna be having a nice cozy chatting stream.
We chatted about a bunch of things that's been going on.
Lots of stuff has been going on.
I feel like it's really overdue right now.
I wanna talk Ruffians.
When was the other potential thing?
Oh that's before.
So look out for that too!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Ruffians joining us in the archive today!
We have FUWAMOCO with... It's BAU BAU!
Live Learnly!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!